bienvenue dans ce allstad les histoires
la pierre Belmar les les stad à
l'ancienne celui-ci je le connais depuis
très longtemps les noms ont été changés
évidemment et il donne une petite leçon
quand même nous sommes en 1937 à Paris
et un homme qu'on va appeler Louis
Jeunet et marchand de sommeil il a un
immeuble qui fait à peu près 5 étages
sur la Place les marchands de sommeil ce
sont des personnes qui louent des choses
qui sont dégradées qui sont insalues qui
sont impropres à la location et ils vont
le louer à des personnes qui n'ont pas
d'autrees choix parce qu'on les refuse
ailleurs Louis Jeunet c'est l'archétype
du mec un peu roublard il est petit il
est un peu ventripotant il a pas l'air
d'avoir les cheveux très propres par
exemple toujours un Mo à la bouche et
donc il il loue des appartements qui
sont meublés qui sont tout petits qui
ont aucun confort il y a les murs qui
sointent il y a de la moisissure partout
et ce sont des pauvres infortunés qui
n'ont pas les moyens d'aller ailleurs
qui n'ont pas la possibilité d'aller
ailleurs qui vont lui louer ses
appartements là lui habite au rez
de-chaussée dans un logement d'ailleurs
qui n'est pas beaucoup mieux seulement
Louis jet le sait pas encore mais depuis
quelques temps il héberge quelqu'un de
très particulier en face de l'immeuble
de louunet il y a un autre immeuble dans
lequel habite Lucienne Lefèvre qui a 60
ans elle est insomniaque et puis elle
est aussi très curieuse donc elle aime
bien regarder et et fourrer son nez un
petit peu partout et la nuit comme elle
ne dort pas elle s'amuse même à observer
ce qui se passe dans les appartements en
face de chez elle un jour elle va voir
Louis jeuner en lui disant attention il
y a quelque chose de très étrange avec
votre locataire du 4e étage Louis Junet
dit c'est Monsieur fichenzo qu'est-ce
qui se passe de d'étrange avec lui et
Lucienne lui dit votre locataire fait
des mouvements très bizarres derrière
les rideaux durant toute la nuit il
arrive à à 23h et à
5h45 il part il éteint la lumière et il
part et donc il ne dort pas la la nuit
c'est c'est étrange pour lui jeuner ça
n'a rien d'étrange monsieur fitchenzo
doit travailler beaucoup la journée et
puis il rentre que la nuit et il va
qu'un peu à ses occupations et et
possiblement il dort parfois la lumière
allumée enfin c'est c'est possible et
puis ma foi ça le concerne pas tellement
parce que Monsieur vitano c'est son
meilleur locataire je ve dire t tous les
mois au premier du mois il pe son loyer
il a jamais eu de problème avec lui mais
pour Lucienne c'est très louche et elle
commence à lui dire si elle se trouve
c'est un terroriste et il prépare des
choses des bombes on sait pas et là au
mot terroriste Louis jeunis commence à
avoir peur je vous rappelle qu'on est en
1937 1937 c'est une époque où il y a
beaucoup de conspirations il y a
beaucoup d'attentats il y a par exemple
la cagoule une organisation politique et
militaire clandestine il y a il y a les
agents de de l'Italie qui sont parfois
présents en France il y a aussi ceux de
l'Allemagne naasie bref le terrorisme on
prend pas ce termel à la légère à cette
époque pour Louis Jeunet ça devient un
souci il aurait jamais parier ça sur
monsieur fichenzo alors malgré son nom
de famille c'est un un Français qui est
est né à colombe qui a toujours bien
payé son loyer et là Louis Jeunet voit
la scène différemment il se dit mais si
paye si bien son loyer tous les mois le
premier du mois c'est peut-être
justement parce que c'est l'argent du
terrorisme qui fait ça Lucienne lui
demande s'il va appeler la police déjà
il veut pas parce qu'il veut pas avoir à
faire avec la police mais en plus de ça
si la police venait et qu'elle
commençait à mettre le nez dans ses
affaires elle découvrirait des
appartements qui sont unpre à la
location des conditions qui sont
lamentables et peut-être même en
creusant le fait qu'il déclare pas
grand-chose si ce n'est rien au fisque
il a peur lou jeuner il fait pas
vraiment le fier mais pourtant va naître
en lui peut-être pour la première fois
de sa vie une forme de courage et de
détermination il va aller se munir d'un
pistolet pour lequel il n'a pas de por
d'arme mais peu importe et il va
découvrir ce que fait monsieur vitenzo à
23h monsieur vichenzo rentre il montre
les escaliers il rentre dans son
appartement Louis Junet attend quelques
minutes pour que monsieur vitenzo va à
ses occupations il monte lui-même les
quatre étages il est en sueur il il est
pas en bonnes condition physique pour
faire ça il a le pistolet à la main il
tremble un peu il utilise le double de
la clé qu'il a de chaque appartement
pour ouvrir celui de Monsieur fitenzo il
ouvre la porte pour le prendre sur le
vif avec l'arme à la main et une chose
est sûre c'est qu'il ne s'attendait pas
à voir ce qu'il veul découvrir devant
lui dans l'appartement veno en plein
milieu de la pièce tout autour de lui
des plaques de zinc des Bages d'acide
des pots de peinture une presse à main
défil à linge c'est un brique à brac
sans nom il est très clair que c'est une
sorte de laboratoire mais un Labau de
fortune c'est pire que le Labau de
Breaking Bad Vincenzo supplie son
propriétaire de ne pas tirer qu' n'a
rien fait de mal et cetera lou il jeé le
somme de s'expliquer et finenzo ne fait
pas de résistance il lui explique qu'en
réalité c'est un faux monayeur qui vient
ici la nuit pour fabriquer des faux
billets et ensuite le jour il les écoule
dans un autre appartement d'ailleurs
appartement dans lequel il dort la
journée c'est cohérent avec tout ce
qu'il y a autour et d'ailleurs dans la
presse à main on voit qu'il y a encore
un billet de 1000 francs qui est encore
humide parce que c'est ça qu'il fabrique
il fabrique des faux billets de 1000
francs alors je vous rappelle qu'on est
en 1937 donc c'est pas les euros et
c'est même pas les Francs qu'il y a eu
avant les euros ce sont les anciens
francs Louis Jeunet voit le fauiller
dans la presse à main l'observe un petit
peu et constate que c'est plutôt bien
imité d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il va dire
à Monsieur vingenzo il va dire bon en
tout cas ça a l'air d'être du bon
travail c'est c'est c'est pas trop mal
imité et là Monsieur vingenzo
étrangement le prend très très mal il
dit non non c'est de l'excellent travail
par contre vous pouvez dénoncer on peut
faire ce qu'on veut mais on peut dire ce
qu'on veut de moi mais je suis le
meilleur dans mon domaine et ce sont les
meilleurs faux billers qui existent 2000
francs et Louis Jeunet est pas si sûr
pour lui il voit quelques défauts et
monsieur vinenzo rentre dans une sorte
de Paris avec Louis jeuné il disait
prenez-le il décroche d'une pince à
linge trois autres billets de 1000
francs dit prenez cela prenez ces quatre
billets demain vous allez chez les
commerçants vous allez à la banque où
vous voulez et s'il y en a un des quatre
qui vous est refusé alors alors là je
m'appelle plus monsieur vigenzo c'est
étrange comme réaction mais c'est
pourtant bien ce qui s'est passé Louis
Jeunet décide de tenter l'expérience il
prend les quatre billet il ressort de
l'appartement et il renferme à clé
monsieur Vincenzo il barricade la porte
c'est son prisonnier en attendant de
savoir qu'est-ce qu'il va en faire Louis
genunet prend son mal la patience pour
attendre le jour suivant parce qu'il a
une idée derrière la tête il sait pas
encore s'il va appeler la police ou pas
si jamais les billets sont refusés mais
si les billets sont acceptés s'ils ont
vraiment la qualité que prétend avoir
monsieur finchenenz
alors il pourrait en faire son faux
monayeur personnel le faire chanter et
l'obliger en fait à le fournir en billet
Louis jeuner commence par aller chez un
buraliste qui a dans sa rue
prèichi il il passe le billet de 1000
francs et il dit au buraliste vérifier
j'ai l'impression qu'on m'a refilé un
faux billet et tout le bualist se
regarde il fait non non c'est un vrai il
lui rend la monnaie luouis g ressort en
seant ok c'est intéressant il part à la
Banque de France avec les trois autres
billets et demande à la Banque de France
de lui faire de la monnaie la petite
coupure mais il leur dit la même chose
j'ai l'impression qu'on m'a filé des
faux billets est-ce que vous pourriez le
vérifier en même temps de toute manière
la Banque de France vérifie toujours les
billets elle va pas les accepter comme
ça sans vérifier elle vérifie les
filigranes le la personne qui est au
guichet regarde tout en détail assure
que ce sont des vrais billets et donc
lui rendent la monnaie en petite coupure
de vrais billets de la Banque de France
sur le chemin du retour Louis Junet est
très satisfait voici ce qu'il va
proposer à Monsieur fincenzo une sorte
d'offre qu'on ne peut pas refuser il va
lu lui proposer de continuer à
l'héberger gratuitement euh peut-être de
l'aider à investir pour optimiser le
matériel et en échange ils devront faire
5050 l'autre proposition hein si jamais
celle-ci est refusée c'est qu'il va le
dénoncer à la police donc il sait qu'il
le tient il sait qu'il y a du chantage
en plus il sait que monsieur fincenzo ne
sait pas que Louis Junet n'aurait pas
trop d'intérêt à voir la police donc qu
qu'il arrive il sait qu'il va arriver à
ses fins il arrive donc au 4e étage il
ouvre la porte enlève la barricade
rentre et explique à Monsieur finingenzo
de oui les billets sont bons il explique
sa proposition et Monsieur fenzo accepte
tout de suite il a pas envie d'être
dénoncé donc il est tenu Louis Jeunet
lui demande combien de billets il peut
fabriquer par jour pour commencer à
compter et monsieurchazo lui explique
qu'il peut faire deux billets par jour
avec cette presse à la main c'est très
très peu beaucoup trop peu c'est très
désevant pour lu jeuner dit mais
qu'est-ce qu'il vous faudrait pour pour
pouvoir produire plus et bien une autre
presse qui n'est pas une presse à la
main là mais une presse hydraulique mais
il ne peut pas se l'offrir parce que ça
coûte 10 millions de francs oui Jenet
redescend dans son appartement réfléchir
non pas sans avoir refermé à clé quand
même la la porte de Monsieur fincenzo
faudrait pas laisser s'échapper la poule
aux odor donc il fait ses comptes dans
son appartement entre ce qu'il a mis de
côté son activité de marchand de sommeil
tout ce qu'il a économisé en ne le
déclarant pas au fisque et il
comptabilise un peu plus de 5 millions
de francs c'est pas assez pour atteindre
les 100 millions pourtant il se dit s'il
arrive à financer cette presse-là une
vraie presse alors il pourrait avoir des
revenus exponentiels il décide d'aller
voir Lucienne Lucienne le fait vous vous
souvenez c'est celle qu' avait prévenu
des allées et venu un peu bizarres de de
son locataire il sait qu'elle est
qu'elle est un petit peu cupide elle
aime bien se mêer de ce qu' la regarde
pas elle est très radine ça pourrait
l'intéresser parce que finalement elle
est pas toujours non plus très clean sur
la loi il va en face il va la rencontrer
lui explique tout deux toute l'histoire
et lui propose de s'associer avec lui
pour payer les 100 millions pour la
machine et de partager maintenant en
trois les Bénéfic Lucienne accepte elle
prend toutes ses économies 5 millions de
francs anciens et la donne à Louis
Jeunet Louis Jeunet a donc les 100
millions qu'il faut et il va retrouver
monsieur vchenzo arrivé à l'appartement
il lui donne les 100 millions de francs
ancien francs en espèce devant lui en
lui disant maintenant va acheter la
presse et c'est parti on n plus des gang
petit là on va pas faire de Bill par
jour fitanzo le remercie énormément
c'est limite s'il se met pas à genoux et
Louis jet profite encore de sa position
comme ça dominante pour dire allez
prends-les et disparaî va acheter la
presse avant que je change d'avis alors
qu'il est évident qu'il n'aurait jamais
changé d'avis vinchenenzo prend l'argent
il disparaît pour de vrai il va jamais
revenir vitenzo il part avec les 100
millions de francs en réalité c'est une
arnaque que pratique relativement
fréquemment fitenzo qui connaît très
bien les profils comme Louis Jeunet ou
même comme Madame Lefèvre d'ailleurs
mais les marchands de sommeil qui sont
toujours prêts en fait à à à déborder
sur la loi à manipuler les autres pour
obtenir de l'argent et donc
régulièrement il fait ça toute cette
mise en scène là c'est-à-dire ce faux
laboratoire les allé est venu la nuit en
attendant que quelqu'un trouve quelque
chose de bizarre et le confronte et là
qu'il avoue qu'il est soit-disant un
faux monayeur soi-disant parce que si
les quatre billets ont bien été acceptés
à la Banque de France c'est parce que
ces quatre billets de 1000 francs
étaient quatre ver véritable billet de
1000 francs donc il a investi juste ces
4000 francs pour avoir 100 millions en
retour le D est rentable et comment on
la connaît cette histoire parce que ce
fameux monsieur fichenzo a été arrêté
pour d'utres délits mineurs et une fois
sur l'une de ses arrestations il a
décidé de raconter à la police toute
cette histoire en entier alors déjà
parce qu'il en était fier et surtout
parce que la police n'a pas pu faire
quoi que ce soit contre lui déjà Louis
Jeunet et Madame Lefèbre évidemment
n'avaient pas porté plainte contre lui
parce que c'est pas très légal tout ça
et même en racontant son histoire la
police ne pouvait rien faire contre lui
puisque quoi qu'il arrive il n'a jamais
fabriqué de faux billets la question est
maintenant est-ce qu'on a vraiment envie
de plaindre un marchand de sommeil qui
exploitait la misère des gens en leur
louant des logements insalumbres j'en
suis pas sûr je dis pas que c'est bien
de faire ce qu'a fait monsieur vcenzo
mais je me dis que par contre sa victime
j'ai pas énormément envie de la plaindre
je vais aussi profiter de cette vidéo
pour vous dire que je suis en tournée
avec mon spectacle c'est un spectacle de
mentalisme d'humour et de science ça
dure à peu près 2hures on se voit à la
fin c'est mon 4è showose comme vous le
voyez à l'écran je serai à Toulon un
petit peu de Suisse Genève Lausanne Gron
ensuite à coulomier à blenau dans le 54
à barleduc dans le 55 à tslesvuges à
pont- Labaie à saint-briux Carcassonne
même le Luxembourg à monondorf lesbain
colemar et encore 25 autres villes vous
avez tous les détails toutes les villes
et la possibilité de réserver dans la
description et la grosse dernière
parisienne au dô de Paris le 5 octobre
ça ça va être fou aussi donc j'espère
qu'on se retrouve dans la vraie vie
sinon on se retrouvera sur internet à
très bientôt Ciao